Right now, I want
to talk about how we got here
and what is going on
and what we can expect going forward.
I want to bring in now our senior
legal affairs correspondent, Paula Reid.
She has been following this
from the very beginning.
Good morning to you.
What are you learning about
still the indictment
and what we have to go through?
And it is still yet to be unsealed.
It's amazing
even the former
president's attorneys
still don't know the charges
that he has been
that have been filed under seal.
Now, that's
because they want to treat him
the same way
they would treat any other defendant.
And what we're expected to see on Tuesday
is that he will go before a judge.
He will be fingerprinted.
He will be photographed again.
They want this to be like any other case.
But, Don,
we know this is
unlike any other case in U.S. history.
A Manhattan grand
jury voting to indict
former President
Donald Trump Thursday
while the case is still under seal.
Sources
tell CNN
he faces more than 30 counts
related to business fraud.
The former president responding
to the indictment
calling the Manhattan
district attorney
Alvin Bragg, a disgrace.
And claiming
the entire investigation is a witch hunt.
He's ready to fight.
You know, he's the toughest guy
I know yet.
And
he was shocked
you know, because we really were
I was shocked
today, the rule of law
in the United States of America died.
The indictment
concludes a yearslong probe
investigating a hush money payment
to adult film star Stormy Daniels
to remain silent about an alleged affair
with Trump.
An affair.
Trump denies the case relies in part
on the testimony of Trump's former
personal attorney,
Michael Cohen,
who has in the past
pleaded guilty to nine federal crimes,
including lying.
I am a convicted felon
and I am a disbarred lawyer, but
I also brought the documents.
There's plenty
of testimony and corroborating testimony
to go around.
Cohen paid Daniels $130,000
just weeks before the 2016
presidential election,
according to court filings.
The Trump Organization reimbursed Cohen
$420,000.
It's a fight against his
rejection of truth
and his manufacturing of stories
that really motivated her.
The Manhattan
District Attorney's Office
was also asking questions
during the grand jury proceedings
about Karen McDougal.
She was paid $150,000
by the company
that publishes the National Enquirer
to stay silent
about another alleged affair with Trump.
Trump has denied
any affair with McDougal.
Trump's longtime friend
and then chairman
of the National Enquirer's
parent company,
David Pecker, is believed
to have orchestrated the payment
and was one of the last witnesses
to testify before the grand jury Monday.
But even Trump's potential
Republican presidential rivals
criticizing the indictment.
Governor Ron DeSantis tweeting
it's un-American.
And Trump's former vice
president Mike Pence,
telling CNN,
I think the unprecedented indictment
of a former president
of the United States
on a campaign finance issue
is an outrage.
And one of the former
president's attorneys,
it tells me that the district
attorney actually
wanted him to surrender today.
That would have been
a really tight turnaround
considering all the security
that they would need to get in place.
They wanted to tamp down the circus
like atmosphere that is sure to follow.
So they want it instead of waiting
till Tuesday over the weekend.
Time for people to gather and so forth.
They wanted him to turn himself in
so that this can be over and done
with at least the appearance
so much for that.
We'll see him on Tuesday write
in what will surely be a circus
like atmosphere. All right.
Thank you very much, Paul Reed.
We'll continue to follow this, Caitlin.
Well,
I think it's important this morning
to step back and look at how we got here.
This didn't just come out of nowhere
and it was back in 2006, actually,
that Trump
first met
both Stormy Daniels and Karen McDougal.
Five years after
that is when Stormy Daniels tried
to sell her story
to a publication known as Life in Style.
But Michael Cohen then working for Trump
started a lawsuit
and the story was never published.
Fast forward to 2015.
Trump announces
that he's running for president.
Of course, he came down the escalator
at Trump Tower
the following spring
that Daniels tries to sell her
story again.
No one bites.
Not even the National Enquirer
that summer.
Karen McDougal story is caught and killed
And remember,
CNN obtained a secret audio tape
at the time of Trump and Cohen discussing
how all of it would play out.
You hear the mention,
David, as in David
Pecker of The National Enquirer,
who also testified this week
before the grand jury.
And Alan,
that's Allen
Weisselberg, who was the CFO of the Trump
Organization.
Is right now
still serving a jail sentence
I need to open up a company
for the transfer of all of that info
regarding my friend David.
So I'm I'm all over that
and I spoke to Allen about it.
When it comes time for the financing,
which will be sure to
wash my hands and we'll have to
pay this off.
Okay. Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
I got it. No, no, no.
A few months after that conversation is
what a bombshell dropped in the Access
Hollywood published a tape of former
President Trump
candidate Trump at the time.
The very next day on October 8th, is
when Daniels seemed to sense
there was opportunity to pitch her story
once again.
After years of failing to sell it.
This time there was interest.
On October 10th,
three days
after the Access Hollywood tape,
and about a month
before the presidential election,
Michael Cohen agreed to pay
Stormy Daniels
$130,000 in exchange for her silence.
That deal threatened Daniels
with severe
financial penalties
if she ever spoke
about the alleged affair on the 28th.
That agreement was signed
11 days before Election Day.
Of course, an election
we now all know Trump won.
Poppy, all of this is is the heart
of what the district attorney
is now looking at,
what they are going into.
It is remarkable
the time that has lapsed here
and the fact that it has culminated
with this indictment
that we saw to walk through from 2006
until where we were
and where we are now is remarkable.
And Caitlin, thank you.
So that's the timeline.
Let's talk about
what came immediately after. Right.
20, 16, 20, 17.
Donald Trump paid Michael Cohen back
with a series of monthly
checks right
$35,000 a month, month
after month, different case.
But when Michael Cohen
was looking at charges,
the DOJ said that those checks
were accounted for as legal expenses,
even though they were not
part of any legal service
that he provided to Trump that year.
So now what?
Hoenig is back are CNN senior
legal analyst okay.
Ali,
let's start, I guess, where we are now,
where we'll be on Tuesday.
What happens now?
So this is historic.
This is unprecedented.
But you know what?
It's just a case as well.
It will be titled
People of the State of New York
versus Donald Trump.
So what are we going to see on Tuesday?
This is what we call an arraignment.
It's a first appearance in court.
Donald Trump
will be, in all likelihood,
fingerprinted.
He may have his mug shot taken as well.
Mug shots,
by the way,
are typically not available
to the public under New York state law.
At that proceeding,
the indictment will be unsealed.
That's when we'll see.
That's
when we'll know what the charges are.
The judge will read the charges
to Donald Trump,
ask him to enter his plea.
He will certainly plead not guilty.
And then the judge will almost
certainly release Donald Trump
and what we call his own recognizance,
meaning come back when you will.
One important thing
I want to notice this court,
what we're going to be is a state court.
It is called somewhat confusingly,
New York Supreme Court.
You hear Supreme Court.
You think of nine justices in robes.
The Supreme Court here
means the trial level court
in downtown Manhattan
After that arraignment,
we're going to be into the trial process.
We're going to have motions
watch for Donald Trump's team
to ask to downgrade or dismiss
some of the charges.
Then Discovery prosecutor
will have to turn over
all their evidence,
good and bad to the defense.
And we will get to a trial.
If there's a conviction,
we will get to sentencing
and then it's all got to go up on appeal.
So we are at the very beginning
and beginning of a very long process.
Let's talk about potential charges here.
John Miller broke the news last night.
This indictment has 30 plus counts.
What could they be?
Yeah, so we know that there's over
30 counts
that doesn't necessarily correlate
with seriousness.
But let's take a look at what it could be
if these charges are based on the hush
money payments
that Caitlin just laid out.
We could be looking at a state charge
for falsification of business records.
The idea
there is
if they falsely log these payments
as attorneys fees,
that would be a misdemeanor
Meaning the maximum penalty is one year.
No one's realistically
going to go to jail on a misdemeanor.
However,
if prosecutors can prove
that those records
were falsified
in order to conceal or commit
some other crime to some second crime,
then we're talking about a Class
E felony. That's the lowest class.
It goes to the max.
There would be four years,
but the judge still has discretion
to give no prison time.
Now, what might that other crime be?
Could be a potential campaign
finance crime.
A little bit of a legal difficulty
there, though, because it's state court.
Remember,
what we're talking about,
a federal election.
Can you
talk, though, Ellie, about the fact
that what the prosecution's
going to have to argue here to try to to
to try to succeed on
these charges
is they're going to try to put a
have to tie a federal crime
to a state charge.
And that is uncharted
and has never been done in this way, ever
in the history of the state of New York.
When you hear Trump's legal team
say these charges are unprecedented,
to an extent, that's not true.
I mean, falsification of business
records show
that this combination,
the way they're doing it,
that's the unprecedented part
that, again, we are in state court here
and they're looking at potentially
charging a violation
of federal campaign law
that's going to go to the judge
before it ever gets to a jury
that quickly trumps defense.
Trump's defense is going to be
the main defense is going to be he's
going to attack Michael Cohen.
Michael Cohen's the star witness.
People can decide.
The jury will decide if they believe him.
Trump's team
is going to point out that Michael Cohen
has been convicted of perjury and fraud,
personal animosity.
I mean, to say the least,
Michael Cohen
despises Donald Trump
and they're going to argue that he's made
inconsistent prior statements.
But Michael Cohen,
the prosecutors are going to argue
he's backed up by other evidence
and you can believe it, or other people,
which Bragg's team may need.
Okay, Kelly, thank you. So helpful.